Profª. Tamar Gendler: Tudo bem.
No final da última aula, eu deixei
vocês com um incrível suspense
que estava no slide, mas... Deixa
eu recapitular rapidamente
para vocês saberem onde
estávamos, terminar aquela aula
e, em seguida, passar para
os temas de hoje.
Como vocês se lembram, no final
da última aula eu falava
sobre uma crítica concreta dos
psicólogos sociais contemporâneos
em relação à teoria
moral de Aristóteles.
Como vocês se lembram,
Aristóteles tem uma teoria moral
cuja noção fundamental é o da
pessoa com bom caráter
– aquele que age como
alguém bem educado,
como agiria a pessoa com a
sabedoria prática.
Aristóteles chama essa
pessoa de phronimos.
E John Doris, no ensaio que lemos,
deu voz a uma preocupação
que vários filósofos têm
manifestado nos últimos anos;
a preocupação de que a teoria
moral de Aristóteles
comete um erro. Ela comete o que
os psicólogos chamam
de erro fundamental de atribuição.
E trata-se da ideia de que é o
caráter, em vez da circunstância,
o principal determinante da ação.
E Doris apresentou uma série de
estudos psicológicos
que pretende mostrar que a principal
determinante da ação é a
circunstância, em vez de uma
característica permanente da pessoa.
Ele nos contou a história dos
caras na cabine telefônica
e sugeriu que é uma característica
maleável do humor o que determina
se as pessoas tendem a ser prestativas,
em vez de uma característica
permanente do caráter.
Ele nos contou a história do
estudo do Bom Samaritano,
sugerindo que foi a circunstância
ou situação que afetou o
comportamento, não as
características permanentes do
caráter.
Nós analisamos os
experimentos de Milgram:
as circunstâncias em que as
pessoas se comportam de maneiras
que é possível pensar que elas
estão fora do caráter.
E falamos anteriormente, e vamos
falar sobre isso de novo,
sobre a ideia da sorte moral:
a ideia de que é possível se
encontrar em circunstâncias
que promovem o comportamento.
Portanto, não há dúvida de que existe
elementos reais na afirmação
de que a circunstância é
um dos principais
contribuintes para o comportamento.
É inegável que existem
circunstâncias que contribuem
para como as pessoas agem.
Mas essa vertente da psicologia social
salientada por Doris é apenas
uma parte da história.
Portanto, além da circunstância
contribuindo para o caráter,
há um grande corpo de
pesquisa na psicologia,
conhecida como psicologia da
personalidade, que analisa
um conjunto de traços que parecem
estar muito bem estabelecidos
nas pessoas no seu 1º ano de vida.
São traços bastante estáveis ao
longo do tempo e que acabam
se correlacionando com uma grande
variedade de outras medidas.
São coisas como a abertura a
novas experiências,
consciência na realização
das responsabilidades,
extroversão em oposição
à introversão,
afabilidade e neuroticismo: um
certo tipo de ansiedade.
Embora seja verdade que a
circunstância desempenha um papel
importante na determinação de
como as pessoas se comportam,
também há contribuições da
personalidade individual.
E uma das obras mais dramáticas de
evidência a favor disso
são os famosos estudos de Walter
Mischel que eu vou discutir
agora e novamente no final da aula.
Parece que, se os estudos de Mischel
– que envolvem milhares de
crianças – são confiáveis,
essa capacidade precoce de
autorregulação ou de adiar
gratificações
em face à tentação é altamente
preditiva em todos os tipos de coisas,
desde as notas no vestibular
até as relações na escola.
As funções sociais e cognitivas
parecem se correlacionar
com certas características da
experiência precoce.
Assim, embora a crítica situacionista
tenha razão, e sem dúvida
é um erro pensar
que a única contribuição para o
comportamento seja o caráter e que
as características do ambiente não
desempenham qualquer papel,
dizer que a única contribuição para o
comportamento é a circunstância
e que não há nenhuma contribuição
por parte do indivíduo
também é enganoso.
E quem estiver interessado ?em analisar
essas diferenças individuais
nas crianças, pode desfrutar
assistindo a alguns dos vídeos
dos estudos de Mischel onde você
vê as crianças sentadas
em frente de marshmallows, desse jeito,
ou assim, ou assim, ou assim.
Ou... coitadinha... ela está destinada
a uma nota baixa no vestibular,
mas... uau! este
marshmallow está
delicioso.
Portanto, qualquer um de
vocês que queira vê-los,
aqui estão 3 apresentações bem
diferentes do caso marshmallow.
E, novamente, estes slides serão
adicionados ao servidor
para o download.
OK.Então este é o
encerramento da última aula
e,
obviamente, um seguimento direto
para o tema da aula de hoje,
a questão sobre a qual iniciamos
esta seção do curso: as
estratégias para regular a si mesmo
diante da fraqueza da vontade.
Agora, enfatizamos na última aula
a imagem de Aristóteles
sobre o que é preciso para que
alguém seja virtuoso.
E Aristóteles disse que, a
fim de ser virtuoso,
é preciso satisfazer 4 condições.
Você precisa saber o que é a
coisa certa a fazer,
precisa decidir fazer essa coisa
porque isso é a coisa certa,
precisa fazê-la de forma estável
e precisa fazê-la de uma forma que não
vá contra as suas inclinações.
Essas são as 4
características
necessárias
para ser virtuoso na imagem
de Aristóteles.
E correspondendo com a virtude, do
outro lado do espectro está
a noção aristotélica de vício, que é
basicamente o seu exato oposto.
É uma tendência harmoniosa,
estável, inteligente e determinada
agir de acordo com o que
exatamente está errado.
Assim, a pessoa viciosa
tem o conhecimento do que é a
coisa errada a fazer,
decide fazê-la porque isso
é a coisa errada,
faz isso de forma estável
e não sente nenhuma inclinação
para fazer a coisa certa.
Portanto, essas são 2 extremidades
do espectro aristotélico.
Na verdade, há 2 coisas que estão
um pouco além da extremidade
do espectro aristotélico.
Como vocês sabem pelo guia de
leitura, Aristóteles
também identifica uma noção um
pouco parecida com o estado
que Jonathan Shay chama de
estado furioso.
É o estado que Aristóteles
chama de bestialidade,
um estado abaixo da virtude e do vício.
E ele dá exemplos de
algumas tragédias gregas
de ferir um corpo membro por membro.
Então, Aristóteles acha que é
possível se ausentar
do reino moral na sua totalidade.
O vício, na imagem aristotélica, é
uma espécie de modo estável
e previsível para agir no mundo.
A bestialidade está abaixo disso.
E, acima da virtude está a ideia
de divindade: um estado
em que a regulação por parte da
virtude nem sequer é necessária.
Mas o cerne da discussão que lemos
no Capítulo 7 do Ética
de Aristóteles se
preocupa com esta extensão de estados
entre a virtude e o vício.
E Aristóteles oferece uma ótima
taxonomia que, afinal,
é útil para entender o que é se
engajar na autorregulação.
Eu gostaria de destacar que não sou
nenhuma estudiosa de Aristóteles
e o que estou oferecendo é uma
reconstrução um pouco artificial.
Mas eu acho que isso é útil
para entender a abrangência
destas distinções.
Para começar, podemos perguntar
como seria um estado que
compartilha com a virtude
o conhecimento sobre a
coisa certa a fazer,
a decisão de fazê-la por esse motivo
e que tem a inclinação, mas
não tem o tipo de caráter
ou a estabilidade lógica que
Aristóteles precisa
para ser um marco da verdadeira virtude?
Esse, eu acho, é o estado que
Aristóteles chama de temperança.
A pessoa está inclinada a fazer a coisa
certa porque é a coisa certa.
E ela sabe o que é a coisa certa.
Mas não existe o tipo de
previsibilidade,
legislação, estabilidade de
caráter que a virtude exige.
Correspondendo com a temperança,
do outro lado da escala
está o que Aristóteles chama de
intemperança, que é,
de certo modo, a imagem
espelhada da temperança.
Aqui, alguém está simplesmente
inclinado a fazer a coisa errada
porque é a coisa errada.
Mas não como uma
característica de caráter
como a apontada no caso de vício,
apenas como uma questão
de temperamento.
Assim, a pessoa temperante, com
inclinação, faz a coisa certa.
Ela está inclinada a fazer a coisa
certa e age dessa forma.
A pessoa destemperada, com inclinação,
faz a coisa errada e não
sente nenhum conflito.
O que acontece se removemos outra
característica aristotélica?
O que acontece se sabemos o que
é a coisa certa a fazer
e a decisão de fazer a coisa
certa, mas a nossa inclinação
nos puxa para o outro lado?
Portanto, nós tomamos a decisão de
agir de acordo com o que é
certo, pelo menos num nível
abstrato, não um concreto,
temos uma noção do que é certo.
Aristóteles afirma, e eu
coloquei essa aproximação
na frente do conhecimento, que
"a pessoa continente e
incontinente tem o reconhecimento
da regra geral, mas algumas
dificuldades em reconhecer
se a regra geral aplica-se
neste caso em particular".
Portanto, a pessoa continente tem
uma sensação da coisa certa
a fazer, toma a decisão de
agir de acordo com isso,
mas sua inclinação a leva
em outra direção.
Ela tem dificuldades para
evitar o bolo de chocolate.
Ela tem dificuldades para se levantar
quando toca o despertador.
Ela tem dificuldades para
resistir ao marshmallow,
a fim de obter outro.
Mas, de alguma forma, ela se contém e
age contra a sua inclinação.
A imagem espelhada da pessoa continente
é a pessoa incontinente
de Aristóteles.
Em termos de decisão, ela é
como a continente.
Ela quer fazer a coisa que
corresponde com a moralidade.
Como a pessoa continente,
ela tem um sentido da regra geral,
um pouco de dificuldade em
ver como se aplica
neste caso particular.
E como a pessoa continente,
ela tem uma tendência a ir em
direção a um prazer que a atrai.
Mas, ao contrário da pessoa continente,
a pessoa incontinente se vê incapaz
de superar a inclinação.
E assim, abaixo na fila, ela age de
acordo com o que está errado.
Por último, Aristóteles
considera uma série de casos
em que a atração para
fazer a coisa errada
não é um desejo de um prazer, mas
um desejo de evitar a dor.
Em alguns casos, a pessoa não recebe o
crédito por ser continente,
não resiste a um prazer, mas
está disposta a se colocar
uma certa dose de desconforto
para fazer a coisa certa.
Aristóteles chama de resistência: a
continência em face da dor.
E correspondendo a isso, mais
abaixo, está a suavidade,
a incontinência em face da dor.
Fazer a coisa errada porque a pessoa
se submete a um certo tipo
de desconforto.
Então eu apresentei esta lista
porque eu acho que não está
completamente claro numa 1ª
ou 2ª ou 3ª ou 4ª
leitura do Livro VII
do Ética de Aristóteles como é
a imagem aristotélica
sobre a alma humana e os seus
pontos fortes e fracos.
Mas eu acho que se observarmos
isso como um conjunto
de características pareadas,
cada uma delas possuindo
ou não certas características da
virtude aristotélica paradigmática,
então podemos ter uma
noção muito clara
do que se parece a imagem aristotélica.
E eu os incentivo, armados
com este quadro,
a voltar ao texto que estamos
lendo e relendo nesta classe:
o texto no final do Livro I
e início do Livro II do
Ética de Aristóteles.
E tentar, mais uma vez,
ver a imagem da virtude que
interessa a Aristóteles.
Então, o que eu quero fazer
no restante da aula...
e vamos precisar dos nossos
clickers em breve...
é falar sobre a ideia de
Aristóteles sobre incontinência.
O que é estar numa
situação onde se sabe
qual é a coisa certa a
fazer, abstratamente.
Alguém está empenhado em
fazer a coisa certa.
Mas tem uma inclinação que
puxa para o outro lado
e cede a essa inclinação.
Então, o 1º que faremos é dar
uma opção para vocês.
E eu deixo claro que esta é
uma pesquisa real.
Tenho aqui o dinheiro,
aqui neste envelope.
E eu tenho aqui... não
estou brincando...
uma lista da turma.
E durante os 10 segundos em que
você estiver respondendo a
esta questão, eu vou fechar os olhos
e escolher um nome da lista.
Portanto, o meu pedido para vocês é...
Vocês têm 10 segundos, assim
que eu iniciar o contador,
para escolher o que querem.
Um de vocês realmente vai
receber US$ 5 agora
ou US$ 6 na quinta-feira.
E pode ser você.
OK. Então, clickers à mão.
Faltam 10 segundos.
OK. Vamos ver as respostas
que foram dadas.
OK. 22% de vocês querem os US$ 5 agora.
78% de vocês querem os US$ 6 em 2 dias.
Sarah Cox? Sarah Cox, você está aqui?
Sarah Cox, o que você escolhe?
Estudante: [inaudível] Profª.
Tamar Gendler: OK. Bem, eu vou
guardar isso comigo
e eu vou colocá-lo na minha cópia
do Ética de Aristóteles.
OK. 22% de vocês, no entanto, queriam
receber o envelope neste instante.
OK, 2ª pergunta.
O que você escolheria? E,
novamente, eu tenho o dinheiro.
Eu tenho um segundo envelope.
Está na minha bolsa.
E você pode escolher entre US$ 5 em
35 dias ou US$ 6 em 37 dias.
OK? US$ 5 em 35 dias ou
US$ 6 em 37 dias.
Votação aberta.
10 segundos.
10, 9, 8... US$5, 35 dias.
US$6 em 37 dias.
Vamos ver os números que saem.
OK. Tudo bem.
O erro experimental de vocês,
pessoal, é ótimo para mostrar
o aspecto do erro experimental
em apertar botões.
Ou talvez alguns de vocês vejam
isso como ser diferente...
OK, 20% de vocês
preferiram levar US$ 5 hoje
em vez de US$ 6 na quinta, embora
quase nenhum de vocês
queira tomar a mesma decisão em 1 mês.
Agora, deixa eu salientar
algo para vocês que,
para a parte racional das suas
almas, é completamente óbvio.
Estas opções são idênticas.
Eu ofereci US$ 5 no dia 15
contra US$ 6 no dia 17.
Ou eu ofereci US$ 5 no dia 22
contra US$ 6 no dia 24.
Quando se trata de 22 de
março, 22% de vocês
que deram respostas
diferentes nestes 2 casos
estarão exatamente na mesma situação
dos US$ 5 e US$ 6 que a dos US$ 5
e US$ 6 imediatamente.
Não há nenhuma diferença
entre esta escolha e esta.
No entanto, os seres humanos e
animais não-humanos
sempre têm uma tendência a começar
a agir de forma diferente com
gratificações atrasadas quando eles
lidam com um futuro distante e quando
lidam com um futuro próximo.
Por muitas décadas, o
psicólogo George Ainslie
estudou as decisões com a seguinte
estrutura: Uma pessoa tem
de escolher entre uma gratificação
menor a ser recebida mais cedo,
como os US$ 5 em vez dos US$ 6, ou
uma gratificação maior
a ser recebida mais tarde. E
Ainslie estudou esse fenômeno
no contexto dos seres
humanos e não-humanos.
Eu vou ler em voz alta uma citação,
que estará nos slides do servidor,
que dá uma noção da
abrangência deste fenômeno.
Ainslie chama de desconto
hiperbólico. E ele diz que
"pessoas (e até mesmo animais)
descontam a perspectiva de uma
recompensa futura numa curva
mais agudamente inclinada do que a
curva exponencial racional."
Então é perfeitamente racional
descontar gratificações futuras
se há incerteza envolvida?
Se eu oferecer US$ 5 agora
ou US$ 6 em 20 anos
faria sentido levar os US$ 5 agora,
porque o seu grau de incerteza sobre
se você receberia os US$6
é suficientemente grande
comparado ao seu grau de certeza
em receber os US$ 5.
Mas a diferença, eu espero,
entre pensar se eu,
vocês e esta sala de aula
estarão aqui na quinta-feira,
ao contrário de daqui a 3
semanas, é trivial.
Ainslie continua: "Ao longo de
um intervalo de atrasos,
de segundos a décadas,
existem pares de recompensas
alternativas tais que os indivíduos
preferem a recompensa menor e mais cedo
em vez da alternativa maior e mais tarde
quando o atraso para a recompensa
menor será curto".Certo?
Aqueles que preferiram US$ 5 hoje
em vez de US$ 6 na quinta.
"Mas eles preferem a
recompensa maior e mais tarde
quando a alternativa menor
será mais tardia."
US$5 dólares em 35 dias
contra US$ 6 em 37 dias.
"Mesmo que o tempo entre a
recompensa mais cedo e mais tarde
permaneça o mesmo.
As curvas que se ajustam
aos dados observados
são hiperbólicas. Ou seja,
eles mostram o valor
como inversamente
proporcional ao atraso."
Então, outra vez, o que
acontece é que,
por um período de tempo A,
a recompensa maior é a
preferida, certo?
Este é você.
Em 37 dias. Em 36 dias. Em
35 dias. Em 34 dias.
Por todo esse tempo, você prefere
os US$ 6 dois dias depois
que os US$ 5 agora ou que os
US$ 5 dois dias antes.
E então, de repente, à medida
que o evento se aproxima,
o valor da recompensa menor se
torna maior na sua mente.
Toda decisão tem essa estrutura.
Vamos supor que você queira treinar
para ser um ciclista competitivo,
ou algum tipo de atleta de elite,
que é a sua gratificação
maior e mais tarde.
Vamos supor que uma das
coisas incompatíveis
com a sua atitude de se tornar
um ciclista competitivo
seja comer cupcakes cobertos com Crisco.
No início, é completamente
evidente para você
que você prefere ser um
ciclista.Você acorda pela manhã e
diz:
"Eu vou traçar o meu plano de
ciclismo. Eu não vou me distrair
com coisas estúpidas como os
cupcakes cobertos com Crisco".
Passa um tempo e ainda está com
você, estão nos seus olhos,
você vê... ahh... a recompensa
de ser ciclista é maior
que a recompensa do cupcake.
E, de repente, com o cupcake
cada vez mais perto,
você opta pela recompensa
menor e mais cedo;
a maior e mais tarde é
excluída das possibilidades.
Vamos supor que você resolva que
amanhã vai se levantar
super cedo para escrever o seu
artigo de Filosofia 181,
também chamada "CogSci 281".
Então você ajusta o
despertador... e tem o toque do
alarme.
E quando você vai dormir,
configura-o para as 5h30.
Você é capaz de ver que a recompensa
maior e mais tarde é a melhor.
E acontece que o alarme toca às
5h30 e você o desliga.
E... oops, lá se vai a possibilidade da
recompensa maior e mais tarde.
Ou vamos supor que você é
um dos indivíduos
de Mischel no estudo do marshmallow.
Aqui está a sua recompensa maior e
mais tarde: 2 marshmallows.
Aqui está a sua recompensa menor e
mais cedo: 1 marshmallow.
Pergunte em abstrato, é muito evidente
para você que 2 marshmallows
é definitivamente melhor que 1
marshmallow até que... até o quê?
Até que você esteja sentado na
sala com o marshmallow
e... oops, você perdeu a sua chance.
Então, o que eu quero fazer no
restante da aula de hoje
é falar um pouco sobre o estado
psicológico das crianças
envolvidas nos estudos de
Mischel e conectar isso
com alguma pesquisa mais geral
sobre a autorregulação.
E, finalmente, conectar isso com a
discussão dos princípios
que tínhamos em nossa
leitura de Nozick.
Portanto, quando Walter Mischel
começou a realizar esses estudos
do marshmallow há cerca de 40 anos,
havia uma teoria de que a
melhor forma de se envolver
na autorregulação era
pensar na gratificação
que você teria se
fizesse a coisa certa.
Nessa teoria, a melhor forma
para as crianças
serem capazes de resistir a um
marshmallow, a fim de obter os
2 marshmallows, seria que o
experimentador deixasse claro a elas
que, se esperassem, poderiam
ter 2 marshmallows.
Assim, as crianças foram levadas para a
sala de uma das 2 condições.
Em uma das condições, havia
1 marshmallow aqui
e 2 marshmallows lá.
As recompensas eram visíveis.
As crianças entravam. E elas duraram,
em média, cerca de 4 minutos
antes de pegarem o único marshmallow,
perdendo assim o 2º.
Quando as recompensas estavam
ocultas, no entanto,
quando as crianças não
podiam ver os marshmallows
e foram levadas para a sala e ouviram
que poderiam ter 1 marshmallow
agora ou, se esperassem por um tempo,
poderiam ter 2 marshmallows...
As crianças esperavam, em
média, 12 minutos.
Então Mischel se perguntou o
que conduzia a capacidade
das crianças com as recompensas ocultas
para elas aguentarem o seu
autocontrole por mais tempo.
Assim, a 2ª condição que ele
provou foi levar as crianças
que estavam na circunstância
em que as recompensas
estavam ocultas e dizer para elas
pensarem com força na recompensa,
pensarem com força
naqueles marshmallows.
O efeito de pensar nos marshmallows
foi que o desempenho caiu
para o mesmo nível
do caso em que as crianças
tinham a recompensa visível.
E, de fato, pensar na recompensa
no caso visível não fez disso pior.
Portanto, o problema era que quando
você pensa na recompensa,
ela se evidencia e a
resistência se torna difícil.
Mischel ponderou: e se
experimentamos isso de outra
maneira?
E se a gente levar as crianças cuja
a recompensa estava visível
e pedir para elas terem pensamentos
felizes sobre outras coisas, certo?
Olhem ao redor da sala,
recitem o alfabeto,
contem a história dos 3 porquinhos,
façam qualquer coisa para se
manterem distraídos.
E o resultado foi que, se as
crianças pensaram em distrações,
elas agiram exatamente
como as crianças na situação
das recompensas ocultas.
E não fez diferença na
situação oculta
pensar em distrações.
Assim, a presença da tentação
na sua mente é parte
do que faz a tentação ser
difícil de resistir.
E, de fato, Mischel refletiu sobre
isso de forma mais geral.
Ele apresentou às crianças uma
fotografia ou um marshmallow
verdadeiro, não importa qual,
e pediu a elas ou para fingirem
que era real ou pensarem
no sabor, no quão gostoso
aquele marshmallow estaria.
E o atraso que as crianças foram
capazes de se impor durou,
em média, cerca de 6 minutos.
Ao passo que, quando as crianças
tinham um marshmallow real
diante delas e tinham de
fingir que era imaginário
ou pensar nisso abstratamente,
pensar no número de marshmallows,
pensar na letra que a palavra
marshmallow começa,
pensar numa loja de doces e
– quero dizer, são
crianças de 4 anos –
pensar como uma loja de doces
trabalha num sentido abstrato...
As crianças foram capazes de se
regularem por 18 minutos.
Então o que estava acontecendo aqui?
O que reúne os casos em que temos
números muito pequenos:
as crianças só são capazes
de durar 4 minutos,
depois cedem à tentação.
E o que reúne os casos em que
temos números grandes?
A hipótese de Mischel, e isso se
encaixa com o material
que discutimos em 20 de janeiro,
é que existem 2 sistemas
de gratificações de processamento.
Há um sistema quente que atua sobre o
que Platão ou Aristóteles
chamaria de apetite, ou
talvez espírito.
Ele age baseado na paixão.
E quando pensamos nas coisas
com uma atração
vívida e emocional, esse
sistema é ativado
e os cavalos de Platão, as partes
não-racionais de Aristóteles,
o sistema 1, os aliefs e
todo o resto flui.
Esse é o sistema ativado
quando as recompensas
são visíveis e não há
nenhuma instrução.
Quando você está pensando
vividamente nas recompensas,
as peças apetitivas da alma
são trazidas on-line
e a resistência à
tentação se torna difícil.
Por outro lado, quando as crianças
são convidadas a pensarem
abstratamente ou fingirem que o
marshmallow é imaginário,
um sistema legal, racional
– um sistema envolvido na
crença do cocheiro de Platão,
do sistema 2 do modelo de duplo
processamento, da tradição alief –
vem à tona.
E diante desse sistema de
processamento legal,
que nos dá uma espécie de distância
racional do que nos confrontamos,
a autorregulação de repente
se torna possível.
Assim, os estudos de Mischel se
encaixam num quadro mais amplo
para pensar em como vencer a tentação.
E vocês não vão se surpreender em
saber que se trata de algo
presente – como quase tudo
tratado neste curso –
numa das duas grandes
narrativas fundadoras
da tradição literária ocidental...
Neste caso, a Odisseia de Homero.
Ulisses, retratado aqui com uma
elegante túnica branca,
está tentando voltar para casa
após a Guerra de Troia.
Ele está tentando voltar para a sua
esposa, que o espera fielmente
em casa, e isso custa cerca de 20 anos.
Ao longo do caminho, durante o
regresso, ele enfrenta
todos os tipos de tentações que
ameaçam desviá-lo do seu caminho.
E a tentação que ele
enfrenta nesta imagem,
na forma destas belas mulheres
voadoras que, para mim, parecem
um pouco como os
dementadores de Harry
Potter.
Ele, no entanto, acha que elas
são enormemente tentadoras.
E ele está tentando encontrar um
jeito de passar pelas sereias,
cujas canções ameaçam
afundar o navio,
para poder voltar para casa
e para Penélope.
E ele desenvolve 2
estratégias diferentes.
A 1ª é aplicada a seus marinheiros.
Vocês vão ver que ao redor
das orelhas de cada um
tem pedaços de algodão.
Eles bloqueiam o som, então o efeito
das sereias é anulado.
Incapazes de ouvir a sua canção,
os marinheiros continuam remando
e superam a fonte de tentação.
O que Ulisses faz com ele mesmo,
como vocês podem ver,
no ponto A da curva de Ainslie,
é se amarrar ao mastro.
Porque, como as crianças de
Mischel e como Ainslie,
ele reconhece que quando o canto das
sereias o atingirem diretamente,
ele vai estar neste estado B,
o da recompensa menor e mais cedo...
como desligar o despertador
ou comer o cupcake.
Então, o que Ulisses faz é
se amarrar ao mastro.
Mesmo que a tentação da
recompensa seja evidente,
ele se tornou incapaz de
agir diante dela.
E há uma tradição, na literatura da
teoria da decisão contemporânea,
que usa a metáfora de
Ulisses e das sereias
(Odisseu e as sereias, dependendo
da tradução utilizada)
para pensar em estratégias
para a autorregulação.
E afinal ela é útil, penso eu, para
refletir sobre essas estratégias
organizadas em 3 categorias.
Se você está tentando superar uma
tentação com a estrutura
que temos visto nesta aula: uma
recompensa menor e mais cedo
que, por causa do desconto temporal,
se torna desproporcionalmente
grande na sua estrutura de decisão...
Uma maneira de contornar isso é por
meio das restrições externas.
Você pode se afastar da
possibilidade de seguir essa
tentação.
Você pode desligar a internet no
seu computador, pode usar
um desses preservativos de
celular, pode se incapacitar
de agir conforme o que vai
desviar você do seu caminho.
Você pode colocar o seu
despertador do outro lado do
quarto,
pode levar os cupcakes para fora
de casa, pode colocar
o seu cartão de crédito num copo
de água no congelador.
Todas essas são formas
de se afastar da possibilidade
de seguir a tentação.
Ou você pode se afastar, de alguma
forma, do apelo da tentação.
Você pode reduzir a utilidade
subjetiva dela para você;
por exemplo, bloqueando os seus ouvidos
para você não perceber que a
tentação está lá.
Portanto, essa é uma forma de
exteriorizar a responsabilidade
pela tomada de decisão.
E é uma forma autorreguladora
extraordinariamente eficaz.
Você é um agente no mundo.
As ações que você está prestes a
executar são ações sobre o mundo.
E se afastar da possibilidade de
realizar essas ações
é uma maneira de dar a
volta à tentação.
Uma 2ª maneira de
contornar a tentação,
que temos discutido muito nas
últimas aulas, é pelo
apelo direto às partes espiritual
ou apetitiva da sua alma.
Assim, você pode manipular as estruturas
de incentivo para você mesmo.
Você pode mudar as utilidades
relativas das várias recompensas.
Você pode se submeter a
pressões interpessoais.
Vocês se lembram que colocamos os
smiles nos computadores
para que os olhos alheios ajudassem
a nos atermos às tarefas.
Ou você pode cultivar hábitos, certo?
Você pode alinhar o espírito e
o apetite com a razão,
cultivando formas naturais de
responder às coisas.
Mas a 3ª forma em torno de tentações
é algo que nós ainda não discutimos,
e se dá por meio da razão.
E é nessa perspectiva que Nozick
discute os papéis que os princípios
podem desempenhar, permitindo que
não sejamos incontinentes.
Nozick destaca, de forma
rápida, que os princípios
agrupam as ações, colocando-as sob
uma rubrica geral, para que
as ações vinculadas sejam vistas
ou tratadas do mesmo modo.
Se alguém assume, como um princípio,
ser vegetariano, então qualquer
ato de comer carne é visto como uma
violação desse princípio.
Mesmo se a pessoa pensar que há
circunstâncias em que comer
carne pode ser a coisa certa a fazer,
considerando todas as coisas.
O que o princípio faz é
classificar esse ato
com outros atos de comer carne, de modo
que as ações se tornam
simbólicas entre elas.
Fumar um único cigarro não é tão
ruim, mas fumar muitos cigarros é.
E uma coisa que um princípio pode fazer
é que você pegue uma postura
como exemplo de todas.
Os princípios, diz Nozick, são uma
forma de nos amarrarmos ao
mastro, não por meio de
restrições externas, como cordas,
mas de compromissos internos.
E ele aponta que os princípios são
eficazes numa série de casos.
Intelectualmente, se você tem a
ideia de que há um princípio
que conecta um conjunto de
fatos com outro,
então o princípio pode
transmitir probabilidade ou apoio.
Os casos antigos resultaram
uma maneira particular.
Toda vez que você notou um
certo tipo de causalidade,
havia uma estrutura particular.
Você identificou um princípio e
agora está em posição
de fazer previsões sobre novos casos.
Interpessoalmente, eles
permitem que você aparente
ser uma pessoa de confiança.
As suas ações passadas seguiram
um determinado tipo, certo?
Toda vez que eu disse que iria dar
dinheiro, eu dei dinheiro.
Assim, vocês podem concluir que
eu tenho um princípio:
pagar as minhas dívidas.
E, com base nisso, vocês preveem
as minhas ações futuras.
É exatamente por isso q
ue eu mudei todos os exercícios
escritos para a quinta,
em vez prorrogar alguns deles.
O meu pensamento foi: vamos supor
que eu tivesse prorrogado
2 dos ensaios de terça para quinta.
Eu faltaria aos princípios no que diz
respeito às regulações deste curso.
Como posso obrigar que as
exigências do curso
sejam cumpridas se eu pareço
não ter princípios?
Ah, vamos supor que eu
adotasse um novo princípio:
o prazo de entrega é na quinta,
em relação a qual eu
estou inabalável?
Um minuto de introspecção.
Estranhamente, isso parece
mais autoritário
que ter a maioria das entregas às
terças e algumas às quintas.
Intrapessoalmente, conceituar-se
com base nos princípios
oferece uma espécie de
continuidade narrativa da vida.
O meu eu passado era o tipo de
pessoa que nunca faria X.
pessoa que sempre fazia Y.
Articular isso com base num princípio
me permite ligar o meu eu
futuro ao meu eu passado.
Isso me dá uma sensação de
continuidade ao longo do tempo.
E, por último, intrapessoalmente,
os princípios fornecem maneiras
de vencer a tentação.
Oh, cada vez que eu vejo um cupcake
tenho vontade de comê-lo,
mas se eu tenho o princípio de
não comer sobremesa
depois das 16h, então é fácil.
Eu não tenho de tomar uma
decisão baseada caso-a-caso.
O simples ato de comer cupcake uma vez.
Por que uma vez? Por que não
fazer isso o tempo
todo é uma forma de me comprometer
com as ações futuras?
Quem toca um instrumento sabe que a
rotina de treino mais fácil é
a prática diária.
Porque se você praticar todos os dias
não carregará a dúvida se hoje é um
dos dias que você tem de praticar.
Se você está empenhado num certo
tipo de comportamento religioso,
um certo tipo de restrição alimentar
ou um regime de exercícios...
o jeito mais fácil de
execução é dizer sempre
que você vai se comportar
segundo esses critérios.
E, na verdade, Nozick sugere
que essa é exatamente
a forma de usar os princípios para
superar a curva de Ainslie.
A marca de um princípio, diz ele,
é que ele amarra a decisão de uma
ação particular imediata
a toda uma classe de ações da qual
o princípio se torna parte.
A ação, agora, dá suporte a várias.
Eu descobri que estou desperdiçando
um tipo de substância de
relaxamento nos fins de semana.
E o jeito mais fácil para
lidar com essa situação
é empregar uma restrição
categórica no meu comportamento.
Além disso, ressalta Nozick,
eu posso usar uma irracionalidade
realmente interessante
para lutar irracionalmente
com a irracionalidade.
Lembrem-se, há algumas aulas eu
indiquei que as pessoas
que perdem uma nota de US$ 10 no
caminho para o cinema
estão dispostas a comprar
um novo ingresso.
Mas as pessoas que perdem um ingresso
no valor de U$ 10 não estão dispostas.
Esse é um exemplo de um fenômeno geral
conhecido como custos irrecuperáveis,
em que quando colocamos
muito esforço em algo,
estamos relutantes em parar de
agir com base nisso,
mesmo se preferimos não fazer mais.
E assim Nozick sugere que, se durante A,
esse período que antecede
a curva Ainslie,
investimos muitos recursos no futuro
em busca do prêmio maior,
o fato de que temos a tendência a não
ignorar os custos irrecuperáveis
nos fornece uma forma de
superar a tentação
durante o período B, para
escolher a menor e mais cedo.
Se eu decidir que quero ir a 6
peças de teatro por ano
e comprar 6 ingressos, então,
mesmo se estiver chovendo numa das
noites que eu deveria ir,
a minha tendência para os
custos irrecuperáveis ??
vai me ajudar a seguir a minha ação.
Tudo bem, últimos 2 minutos.
Eu vou conectar isso tudo ao que
fizemos e para onde estamos indo.
Esta, como se sabe, é a última
aula da 1ª unidade do curso.
Começamos esta unidade com a
leitura do popular capítulo de
Predictably Irrational de Dan
Ariely e acabamos esta unidade
com a leitura do popular
capítulo sobre procrastinação
de Predictably Irrational de Dan Ariely.
Mas, ao contrário da experiência
de vocês em 11 de janeiro,
agora vocês têm uma base filosófica
para se posicionarem na discussão.
Ao contrário de 11 de janeiro,
agora vocês têm um quadro
psicológico para se posicionarem.
Vocês leram Haidt, leram Batson, leram o
trabalho de duplo processamento,
leram Milgram, Shay, Stockdale e Kazdin.
E vocês já leram a
apresentação científica do
caso
e já pensaram sobre as
conexões entre eles.
O que vem a seguir? O que vem a seguir,
nos seus exercícios dirigidos 5
e 6, é a oportunidade
de abordar 3 artigos de psicologia
que vocês vão escolher
e resumir e, em seguida, realizar a
um experimento baseado nisso.
O que vem a seguir é a oportunidade de
refletir sobre a base filosófica
escrevendo o 1º e 2º
ensaios de vocês.
E, no final do curso, já
posso prever isso agora,
será a oportunidade de
refletir sobre as conexões
entre eles no âmbito do seu
exercício dirigido final.
Que será projetar 1 semana do
curso, em que você
escolhe os textos que acha
que auxiliam no entendimento do tema.
Portanto, na próxima aula vamos
seguir adiante na nossa discussão
sobre a moralidade. E eu vou
reconectá-los com algumas das
questões
que comentamos até agora.
Estou ansiosa para vê-los na quinta
e, especialmente, para dar os US$ 6
para a aluna muito racional que
teve a sorte de ganhá-lo.